(The Super Late Morning Show theme music)
(turn table screech)
(Breaking News theme)
- Breaking news man, we got breaking news.
We're going live to our field
reporter, Rev Donaldson.
(dramatic music)
- Thank you Keith and Kenny.
We are live on the scene here
where some information has surfaced,
possibly saying that the
legendary rapper Tupac Shakur
is indeed still alive.
If you'll follow me right here camera man,
there's a Timberland
footprint at 11 and a half.
The exact size Tupac Shakur wore.
(dramatic music)
- Pac's footprint?
- It's hard to say Keith or Kenny.
These shoes are very
popular with the negroes.
They love a good Timbaland.
Tupac conspiracy theorists believe that
if you yell out to
Tupac, he will call back.
Let's try it.
West side!
- [Someone] West side!
- [Tupac Audio] West side.
- [Mystery Audio] West side.
(computer noises)
- [Computer] Tupac identified.
- Let's go.
(dramatic music)
We might've just heard Tupac Shakur.
Who knows?
Oh my god!
Oh my god that was, was that Tupac?
Was that him? Or was it
just another black guy?
Who can tell? They all look alike.
I'll tell ya,
big penises on those guys.
Let's go back to the studio.
(dramatic music)
- Thanks Rev, that was
incredibly racist but you're
the best in the business
and he knows how to track Tupac
like the best of them so...
(hip hop music)
(high pitched buzzing)